hello guys i'm ryan right i'm gerry it's
Christmas everybody it's chrimbus it's
chrimbus it's Christmas and I wanted to
say Merry Christmas my gift to all of
you is me uploading this video today oh
boy so you can see a little bit more r
i'm gerry be like sing a song or should
be known to anything although I do have
an announcement I want to make I haven't
ran this by Jerry yet I wanted to get a
physical live reaction I know who's
Jerry you're Jerry [ __ ] ok I have this
idea to get subscribers more involved in
this channel oh boy life everything to
do is when I can feature a subscriber
like in a picture or video and yeah so
special gift I thought of a fun thing
and you guys are gonna like this it's
tee tees delicious it's uh it's often
good for your show all right shut up i'm
filming you're just here you're leaning
on my leg what like a desk it's
Christmas because of course mrs.
cratchit mistletoe up there cummings
guys suck your balls that's imagine how
strange parties would be sure oh god oh
god please all of the real missiles I
don't wonder what my balls on this
channel no the announcement is this I
know a lot of you guys are movie lovers
and movie buffs which makes a lot of you
guys film students and makes a lot of
you guys and you know who put a lot of
you guys put together yeah you don't
have to be lairs movie buffs but I like
the fact that a lot of these subscribers
actually go out of their way to make
short films and sketches here's what I'm
proposing you guys if you did a sketch
or a short film Jeff that's what I'm
limited to you for now sketch or short
sketch or short film not a vlog not like
some random video you uploaded has to be
a sketch or short film and if you guys
have done those send them my way will
react to them and we'll review them
honestly so we don't like it I'm sorry
but that's the consequence that you're
paying for on yeah you're paying for
honesty so you can submit it will tell
people what your channel
is if you want to check out more videos
if you guys have friends or no other
youtubers that you want to hit up and
tell them to you know submit a video or
something that'd be cool because I want
to check out more short films and
sketches and it'd be awesome to see what
the subscribers can do to ya hey if
you've always been wanting to put a
sketch together but just didn't you know
have the time resources or wherewithal
to do it maybe now is the time now is
the time get on it make that first skin
that's what I want to do at least once a
week or twice a week in 2015 2016 every
day a week every day a week 365 short
reacts and where to submit it in the
description box at the top there's an
email that I've just created you can put
the submissions there please don't send
me a video that is not a sketch or short
film yes something narrative probably
with editing and things like them yeah
angles and we'll give a shout out to
your channel that way we you know get
you gas prone to to this is no talking
about and market Aaron marketing you get
the subs we're in bold you get the
subscribers more involved this is me
really in subscribers it works how's
everybody means its exposure this is me
did this you know this is this is very
small violin and playing the smallest
violin it's not the time for that yeah
it is I don't tip want you to dip I
don't believe in it like a virgin dollar
but a guy with a big dick you can see
but like a virgin's about it's all about
a girl who looks a guy with a big dick
tell us about dick dick dick dick dick
dick dick what's happening this video
subscribe dance and make merry Christmas
to that email subscribers Amit happy
Hannukah Hannukah zone yes happy new
year if you're watching this after
Christmas and Happy Hanukkah unto all
the jurors subscribers yeah man Hanukkah
yeah and to all the atheists you don't
get to celebrate Christmas no I mean now
they're sec it's Jesus Christ birthday
not real I mean they said it was
probably in April or something
this matter we mostly Christ mamii
morphed it around the pain must attend
catholic mass in Rome for for our mass
so get those plane tickets